helme und abwehrraketen ja
kampfflugzeugen ein so die klare
botschaft von bundeskanzler scholz und
auch der nato in richtung ukraine die
usa wollen auf keinen fall eine
ausweitung des krieges produzieren noch
ist ein waffenstillstand nicht in sicht
flucht korridore nicht verlässlich die
menschen weiter im größten leid der
angriff putins war eine zeitenwende und
hat auch in deutschland ein umdenken in
der sicherheitspolitik ausgelöst nur
wenige tage nach kriegsbeginn
überraschte kanzler chance mit dem
versprechen von viel mehr geld für das
militär 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr ausweg oder irrweg unser
thema in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
guten abend aus berlin ich darf ihnen
meine gäste vorstellen der krise ist bei
uns von der spd erst stellvertretender
vorsitzender der bundestagsfraktion und
war zuvor beauftragter für russland und
unter anderem auch die ukraine der
bundesregierung und ich begrüße andré
wüstner er ist oberst des heeres und
bundesvorsitzender des deutschen
bundeswehrverbandes
zugeschaltet ist uns jan van aken von
der linken er war von 2009 bis 2017
mitglied des bundestages und
außenpolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion und heute arbeitet er für die
rosa-luxemburg-stiftung und ebenfalls
zugeschaltete marina comeback sie ist
politische reporterin für das
medienportal pioneer mit dem schwerpunkt
außen und sicherheitspolitik herr wiese
zwei wochen sind seit dem angriff auf
die ukraine vergangen es ist immer noch
eine katastrophe für die menschen in der
ukraine die zeigt sich aber trotz
russischer übermacht ja dort sehr
wehrhaft sollte man noch mehr
militärisch unterstützen damit die
ukraine den russen standhalten kann sie
sprechen es an ich glaube russland hat
die
kampfbereitschaft der ukraine
unterschätzt russland hat unterschätzt
wie tief die gräben auch seit 2014
zwischen russland und der ukraine schon
geworden sind wie viel wut hass und
verärgerung auch aus der bevölkerung den
russischen streitkräften
entgegenschlägt letztendlich auch wir
haben ein zeichen gesetzt wir haben uns
abgestimmt mit unseren verbündeten die
ukraine auch zu unterstützen dabei muss
man allerdings auch immer wieder
deutlich machen dass wir nicht
konfliktpartei sind die nato hält sich
ja bewusst aus diesem konflikt auch
heraus damit die eskalation nicht
weitergeht damit sie auch nicht zu uns
hinüber schott letztendlich aber die
unterstützungsmaßnahmen die die
bundesregierung angekündigt hat die
waffenlieferungen auch die maßnahmen die
olaf scholz in seiner
regierungserklärung angekündigt hat ich
glaube die sind richtig und der
situation situation auch dringend
erforderlich
trotzdem wenn man heute bilder sieht wie
eine geburtsklinik bombardiert wird wenn
man ist es ein grundsätzliches dilemma
weil präsident seelands geht aus der
ukraine sagt wir brauchen die
flugverbotszone wir müssen
wehrhafter werden ist es dann nicht ein
punkt wo man sagt doch mal müsste
kampfflugzeuge sowie die polen es ja
machen wollten die mit 21 man müsste die
auch bereitstellen für die ukraine die
bilder die wir heute wieder gesehen
haben sind grausam sie sind letztendlich
auch kriegsverbrechen sie gehören
letztendlich der dokumentiert und sie
müssen auch zur verantwortung gezogen
werden aber nochmal die einrichtung
einer flugverbotszone durch die nato
wäre ein unmittelbares eingreifen in
diesen krieg was auswirkungen hätte
massive auswirkungen auch auf uns hier
ich kann alles verstehen was die ukraine
anforderungen auch an uns richtet
trotzdem ist es wichtig immer wieder in
absprache innerhalb der nato innerhalb
der europäischen union mit unseren
partnern trotz aller eskalation besonnen
auf diese situation zu reagieren und
darum halte ich die entscheidungen keine
flugverbotszone aktuell einzurichten
auch für richtig er wüsste wie sehen sie
ist die ukraine will eben weiter diese
militärische unterstützung was bedeutet
das wenn man in diesem krieg ist aber
nicht genug ausrüstung und sich
letztendlich nicht wirklich so wehren
kann wie man sich gerne wären würde naja
mit blick auf die menschen vor ort und
deren betrachtungswinkel ist es
natürlich eine wirklich schwierige
situation und wenn wir uns dort hinein
fühlen dann geht es uns wahrscheinlich
allen so dass wir unmittelbar helfen
wollen und auch der auffassung sind wir
müssten eigentlich alles liefern aber
wir hatten es ja gerade schon gehört ist
es eine frage inwieweit man tatsächlich
hilft mit welcher art von
waffenlieferung und wie weit man nicht
eine eskalationsspirale in gang gesetzt
die wir eigentlich nicht in gang setzen
wollen denn gerade der der punkt sie
nannte den vorschlag stichwort
luftfahrzeuge zu liefern zur verfügung
zu stellen dass es etwas das kann
provozieren und das kann uns in diesen
krieg hinein saugen und das eben zu
anderen maßnahmen putins führen die wir
nicht wollen stichwort nukleare option
und alles was dazugehört da muss man
sehr sensibel sein es ist ein ritt auf
messers schneide würde ich fast sagen
ritt auf der rasierklinge inwieweit man
auf der einen seite unterstützt und
dieses recht auf selbstverteidigung mit
bedient dass ich absolut nachvollziehen
kann und auf der anderen seite eben
schon auch sagen muss 'wo ist eine
grenze ja das optimale deutschland auch
keine abwehrraketen liefern und hat dann
gesehen die werden doch sehr gebraucht
ja wie soll ich sagen minister habe hat
es ja glaube ich am tag des angriffs
gesagt vielleicht war man tick zu naiv
in deutschland in europa mit blick auf
die gesamtsituation
wir als verband haben immer darauf
hingewiesen dass man auf der einen seite
natürlich diese option in den blick
nehmen kann auf der anderen seite wir
natürlich die probleme selbst haben in
der bundeswehr und uns jetzt diese
selbst auch panzerabwehrhandwaffen mehr
oder weniger auf den rippen schneiden
und deswegen das aktuell darauf ankommt
dass wir die die wir geliefert haben
schnell nach beschaffen aber aus dem
blickwinkel der ukraine kann nicht
verstehen dass die sagen wir wollen uns
hier verteidigen und ja man kann das
abstract natürlich auch anders sehen
aber ich kann es nachvollziehen herr van
aken sie haben sich immer gegen
waffenlieferungen
ausgesprochen aber angesichts dieses
leids und des bombardements was da jeden
tag passiert einen unzuverlässigen also
bestimmte dinge der die flugkorridore
werden nicht eingehalten all das gibt es
da momente wo sie sagen doch man müsste
doch waffen liefern
das gefühl habe ich auf jeden fall das
ist ja überhaupt gar keine frage ich
glaube wenn ich jetzt in tier wäre dann
würde ich wahrscheinlich dass auch mit
waffen verteidigen ich bin kein
radikaler ist
und dann ist das eine sozusagen diese
emotionale reaktion das ist grauenvoll
dieser angriffskrieg und dass dort die
dort gerade zivilisten bombardiert
werden wohngebiete bombardiert werden
krankenhäuser das muss ja irgendwie
gestoppt werden und dann gibt es im
zweiten stück zurückzutreten und das
emotionale nach hinten zu schieben und
zu sagen ja aber was könnte den rational
wirklich am sinnvollsten turnier von
deutschland aus und man da ein bisschen
länger darüber nachdenkt gibt glaube ich
andere hebel die nicht militärisch sind
die viel effektiver sein können wenn man
sich vorstellt dass der westen also usa
und europa zusammen jeden tag jeden
einzelnen tag 600 millionen dollar an
russland überweisen für öl kohle und
erdgas von diesen 600 millionen dollar
könnten dann gucken sich jeden tag neue
panzer kaufen so viele waffen kann man
gar nicht liefern also insofern glaube
ich müssen wir viel stärker noch darüber
nachdenken wie kann man ohne
militärische mittel das gleichgewicht so
verändern dass nicht noch mehr menschen
leiden müssen in der ukraine
frau kombi kompakt sie beobachten diese
politische diskussion zuerst dieses jahr
beliefern 5000 helme dann doch die
abwehrraketen jetzt ein klares nein
gegenüber den kampfflugzeugen wie klar
ist da ihrer meinung nach die
bundesregierung wie klar ist da der
bundeskanzler
bundeskanzler olaf scholz
außenministerin aller dinge berbalk die
gesamte bundesregierung ist getrieben in
dieser frage ein ums andere mal musste
sie ihre position einräumen ein ums
andere mal musste sie das tun was sie
kurz zuvor noch ausgeschlossen hatte das
nein zur lieferung von kampfjets an die
ukraine ist ein sehr klares das haben
wir von mehreren regierungsmitgliedern
jetzt vernommen aber ja die vergangenen
beiden wochen haben uns eines gelehrt
dass das nein von gestern morgen auch
schon wieder ein jahr sein kann also mit
prognosen vorsichtig okay wir haben auch
gelernt grundsätzlich dass man völlig
umdenkt in der sicherheitspolitik
alle waren überrascht von der rede von
olaf scholz am sonntag nach dem
kriegsbeginn wo er dann angekündigt hat
dass es ein sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr geben soll in höhe von 100
milliarden euro wie überrascht waren sie
eigentlich davon ich war bedingt
überrascht man hat das jetzt in den
wochen vorher schon immer wieder
besprochen bezogen auf den zustand der
bundeswehr und auf bezogen auf den
grundgesetzlichen auftrag also stichwort
der bund stellt streitkräfte zur
verteidigung auf und wir wissen und
haben es ja hier schon öfters diskutiert
mindestens jährlich mit blick auf die
würdigte der wehrbeauftragten dass wir
diese befähigung zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung in derart nicht mehr
haben hängt an der reform 2010/11
mancher innerlich sich noch an herrn zu
guttenberg und dem was daraus passiert
ist und jetzt wurde mehr oder weniger
das klar was wir immer wieder in den
letzten jahren beschrieben haben dass
diese bundeswehr auf ertüchtigung
einsätze wie vergleichbar nordirak mali
ausgerichtet wurde aber die grund
befähigung zu landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
abgestimmt im bündnis also nato und eu
in der form nicht mehr hat und ein
ablagefach sie waren eingebunden und und
sozusagen vorrechnen dass man 100
milliarden braucht also das war
eigentlich klar und spielte schon eine
rolle im zuge der
koalitionsverhandlungen diese summe auch
mit blick auf die lücken die wir in der
bundeswehr haben bezogen auf den auftrag
landes und bündnisverteidigung und jetzt
war es eine frage wie man damit umgeht
hätte man nicht dieses sondervermögen in
den fokus genommen das muss ja auch
immer noch durchs parlament aber dann
wäre klar gewesen selbst mit einer
leicht ansteigenden finanz linie hätten
wir vor dem hintergrund unserer
steigenden betriebskosten und alles was
dazugehört in einen abbau gehen müssen
und dass in der jetzigen situation hat
viele doch zum nachdenken angeregt und
ich sage es nochmal es hat nicht in
erster linie nur was mit der aktuellen
situation in der ukraine zu tun ist eine
frage wie wir innere und äußere
sicherheit als kern staatlichen handelns
verstehen wie wir selbst der auffassung
sind dass wir in europa in der nato
unserer sicherheitsarchitektur stärken
wollen und ich sag's bewusst auch bei
auf eine lange linie wir wissen nicht
wie ein nachfolger von präsident biden
grundsätzlich das thema europa und
sicherheitsarchitektur sieht und
deswegen ist es für schützt ist nur auf
den ukraine konflikt zu beziehen hat man
immer auf diese zwei prozent ziel des
bruttoinlandsproduktes für die fürs
militär auszugeben herr wiese es gab
eine menge menschen die schon überrascht
waren in ihrer fraktion auch gerade auch
von dieser zahl 100 milliarden ist das
etwas was bei in ihrer fraktion jetzt
unstrittig ist weil es gibt ja in ihrer
fraktion durchaus menschen die
eigentlich nicht für eine aufrüstung
sind es gibt in der spd
bundestagsfraktion eine breite
zustimmung die bundeswehr adäquate und
vernünftig auszurüsten und das ist ja
genau das was mit diesen sondervermögen
von 100 milliarden euro auf den weg
gebracht werden soll deshalb
unterstützen wir das eindeutig und ich
sage das auch sehr deutlich es war noch
sehr viele bei uns schockiert überrascht
fassungslos dass wir wieder einen krieg
in europa haben das muss dann einen
flächendeckenden völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine gestartet
hat und das hat bei vielen auch zu einem
umdenken geführt die vielleicht sich
nicht jeden tag mit außen- und
sicherheitspolitik beschäftigt haben
denn das parlament ist auch ein
parlament das arbeitsteilig arbeitet
nicht jeder beschäftigt sich täglich mit
diesen fragen aber es ist eine
zeitenwende die wir gehabt haben genau
wie es oder scholz gesagt hat und darum
gibt es an breite unterstützung das
jetzt auch auf den weg zu bringen die
man natürlich auch mit der
parlamentarischen rückkopplung denn alle
entscheidungen letztendlich über
haushaltsmittel trifft das parlament
trotzdem hat man vorher dann nicht gut
genug hingeschaut denn der
bundeswehrverband hat ja schon lange
gewarnt dass die bundeswehr nicht genug
wenn ich gut genug gerüstet ist der
bundeswehrverband hat immer wieder den
finger in die wunde gelegt das ist
vollkommen richtig gerade wenn es um die
ausrüstung geht übrigens auch weitere
fragen wie attraktivität bundeswehr als
arbeitgeber und weitere fragen die immer
wieder angestoßen worden sind aber noch
mal das ist auch in den vergangenen
jahren einiges gemacht worden wir haben
von 2014 bis
2021 ein aufwuchs von 30 auf 50
millionen im verteidigungshaushalt
letztendlich schon gehabt aber noch mal
das was die bundeswehr braucht zur
bündnis und verteidigungsfähigkeit dafür
sind dieses sondervermögen dringend
erforderlich und das werden wir jetzt
auch auf den weg bringen wir hätten
eigentlich kurz an jetzt ist es
vielleicht auch dieser kurswechsel der
jetzt deutlich wurde also kommt aus
einer zeit noch wandel durch handel und
jetzt dialog aus einer gewissen
wehrhaftigkeit ich glaube das ist das
was ich zumindest in vielen gesprächen
auch mit parlament eine jetzt erlebe
dass man gelernt hat jetzt in diesen
tagen dass man auf der anderen seite
menschen hat da glaubt man einen dialog
erkennt ihn aber nicht und das ist jetzt
eine art paradigmenwechsel zuletzt habe
ich gelesen der größte kurswechsel seit
der wiederbewaffnung in den 50er jahren
das ist etwas besonderes und das treibt
jetzt viele um und natürlich ich könnte
sagen auch ich als vater würde geld sehr
gerne in bildung und vieles andere
investieren aber der punkt ist die welt
ist wie sie ist und wenn wir es ernst
meinen mit dem auftrag der im
grundgesetz vor ort ist mit einer
wehrhaften demokratie
dann brauchen wir streitkräfte die den
namen auch verdienen mit blick auf die
verteidigungsfähigkeit herr van aken wie
wie sehen sie das es ist ja 100
milliarden euro ist wirklich ein riesen
batzen geld
wie sehen sie diese neuausrichtung wie
bewerten sie das herr fragen
das das erste was ihr wichtig ist das
was der minister gesagt hat das hat
jetzt mit der mit dem russischen angriff
auf die ukraine relativ wenig zu tun
dass es vorher diskutiert worden klug
genug diese situation auszunutzen die
100 milliarden die er für die bundeswehr
wollte wo es widerstand gab in seiner
partei spd sehr große ablehne
bevölkerung jetzt ausgenutzt wunderbar
hat er klug gemacht jetzt habe ich den
salat ich bin ja ganz gern wiese da sagt
man muss die die bundeswehr adäquat um
vernünftig ausstatten würde ich auch
sofort unterschreiben die frage ist doch
aber wofür
und wenn wir irgendwas aus 20 jahren
afghanistan krieg gelernt haben ist doch
dass es eigentlich ein fehler ist die
bundeswehr auf auslandseinsätze zu zu
steigern und ich glaube wenn wir
zurückkommen auf das was man im
grundgesetz stand nämlich
landesverteidigung denn es wirklich nur
noch eine bundeswehr ist die sich gegen
eine möglicherweise bedrohung durch
russland jetzt verteidigen können muss
aber all das andere was in den letzten
20 jahren neu dazugekommen ist mit
auslandseinsätzen von mali bis
afghanistan bisschen kosovo und sonst
woher diese ermächtigung einsätze die
ausbildung einsätze wenn wir all das
weglassen was glauben sie wie viel geld
wir sparen würden dann würden wir nicht
100 milliarden extra in die hand nehmen
müssen wir würden geld bereits
zurückbekommen
deswegen würde ich sagen lassen sie uns
doch endlich mal drüber reden wofür
brauchen wir die bundeswehr wirklich ich
möchte keine auslandeinsätze das waren
die allermeisten menschen in deutschland
auch nicht und wenn wir sagen dann ist
verteidigung gegen russland spare geld
und dann bin ich sofort für eine
vernünftige ausstattung da gibt es nicht
nur warme schlimmer für die soldatinnen
und soldaten dann gibt es auch noch
andere waffensysteme bei wirkt ist so
viel einsparen dass die fläche ich
glaube der wissener der herbig werde und
wir würden sehr viel geld sparen der
sozialist und die frage ist aber wie wir
dann unter unserer internationalen
verantwortung gerecht werden frau
kompakt was was erwarten sie welche
diskussion erwarten sie auch noch was
wir haben ist ja klar das ganze muss ja
da ist parlament das wird ja nicht
einfach so durchgehen was erwarten sie
auch gerade zum beispiel von den grünen
dann
also ich bin ein wenig überrascht über
die einmütigkeit die herr wiese in
seiner partei in seiner fraktion
ausgemacht hat mein eindruck ist nah
doch ein anderer die sendung heute trägt
den titel 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr ausweg oder irrweg das wort
ihre weg kommt von der senioren
abteilung der der spd die senioren in
der partei haben diese entscheidung
diese verkündung als irrweg tituliert
und sie sind da nicht allein die
juso-vorsitzende
rosenthal die jusos in der fraktion
trommeln mächtig dagegen dass diese 100
milliarden die jetzt vom kanzler ins
schaufenster gestellt worden sind
ausschließlich ins militär fließen und
derselbe derselbe widerspruch kommt auch
von den grünen auch da gibt es in der
fraktion mächtiges unbehagen angesichts
der vorstellung all dieses geld in die
bundeswehr zu geben ist wird jetzt ich
denke wir stehen kurz vor einem jahr
doch sehr munteren
koalitionskonflikt innerhalb der ampel
die diskussion ist eröffnet was
sicherheit heute eigentlich bedeutet
sicherheit beschränkt sich sicherheit
auf investition ins militärische oder
möglicherweise auch in
entwicklungszusammenarbeit in humanitäre
hilfe in diplomatie diese frage ist
ehrlich gesagt bereits vor der ampel
beantwortet und zwar in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag wo vermerkt ist dass
ausgabensteigerungen in der verteidigung
einhergehen mit ausgabensteigerung in
diesen anderen bereichen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit humanitäre
hilfe und davon hat scholz bislang ja
wenig erkennen lassen und darauf pochen
jetzt weist auf die grünen verwiesen die
grünen pochen da jetzt darauf dass
ausgabensteigerungen für die bundeswehr
einhergehen mit ausgang steigerung in
anderen bereichen aber wieso wie viel
krach oder wie viel diskussion debatte
wird es dann noch geben auch mit ihren
koalitionspartner den grünen ich will
jetzt nicht anmaßend klingen aber ich
bin ja doch ein bisschen näher dran an
der spd bundestagsfraktion und der leber
auch unsere internen debatten und ja wir
diskutieren darüber ja man muss auch
immer wieder deutlich machen dieses
sondervermögen hat keine auswirkung auf
den derzeitigen bundeshaus das ist ja
auch ein bisschen vermischt worden herr
van aken hat es ja gerade angedeutet
jetzt steht weniger geld für soziales
zur verfügung das ist ja eindeutig nicht
der fall darum machen wir ja auch ein
sonderfall muss das geld ja woher kommen
das ist vollkommen richtig aber es ist
ein sondervermögen was aufgenommen wird
und was nicht auswirkungen unmittelbar
auf dem bundeshaus jahre bezieht sich
diese sonderform weil da gibt es auch
unterschiedliche informationen da sind
wir mittlerweile dabei der
haushaltsausschuss und wir nehmen die
arbeit letztendlich auch auf und
übrigens keine mittel die über 25
millionen euro weil beschaffungsvorhaben
rausgehen geht ohne einen beschluss des
haushaltsausschusses des deutschen
bundestages also es ist auch nicht ohne
kontrolle aber nochmal in der spd
bundestagsfraktion gibt es breite
unterstützung ja es gibt die eine oder
andere stimme die auch nachfragen hat
die diskussionen führt das ist aber auch
völlig verständlich bei so einer
situation nur wir haben auch eine
situation dass wir erstmalig auch wieder
einen krieg in europa haben und das muss
man auch wieder deutlich machen darum
bin ich auch bei dem was er verlauten
gesagt hat dass man
schauen muss wofür ist die bundeswehr
zuständig aber dass man jetzt
rückschlüsse afghanistan male jetzt mit
einfließen lässt wir haben hier eine
besondere situation dieser müssen wir
uns auch außen und sicherheitspolitisch
mit unserer verbündeten stellen und da
glaube ich ist die antwort die olaf
scholz und die bundesregierung habt
gegeben hat auch angemessen aber noch
mal wird es für die bundestagsfraktion
haben dafür eine breite zustimmung und
sind sie und diese frage dass man dann
auch genauso viel geld in die hand nimmt
dann zum beispiel für
entwicklungspolitik ist das dann
funktioniert das wir das funktionieren
es muss letztendlich einen
ganzheitlichen ansatz an vielen stellen
geben und wir haben auch noch weiter
herausforderungen aber die werden sich
dann alle grad im bundeshaushalt wieder
finden und das ist ja genau die
diskussion die wir darüber letztendlich
auch führen es gibt auch
herausforderungen im zivil und
katastrophenschutz die wir auch angehen
müssen die genauso gut zu diesen
ganzheitlichen sicherheitsbegriff
gehören aber nochmal das sind ausgaben
die sich im bundeshaushalt wieder finden
und das andere ist das sondervermögen
von 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr ja
er wüsste wofür würden sie das geld am
liebsten einsetzen wo sagen sie dafür
brauchen wir das bei der bundeswehr es
geht um alle fähigkeiten die wir
klassisch für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung brauchen es ist
immer schwer das nachzuvollziehen wir
hatten großen großen haushalt und wieso
funktioniert das nicht und dann muss man
immer wieder erklären in 2010 11 wurde
diese bundeswehr ausgerichtet auf
kleinste ertüchtigung einsätze und alle
fähigkeiten nahezu für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung wurden abgebaut die
haben wir kaum noch es ist so wie wenn
sie die münchner berufsfeuerwehr nämlich
mal das beispiel
damit
beauftragen und auch so strukturieren
und verkleinern dass sie nur noch keller
ausgepumpt und alle spezialfahrzeuge und
leiter fahrzeuge die schaffen sie ab und
von heute auf morgen kommen sie doch
wieder darauf dass es für großbrände in
industrieanlagen gar nicht so schlecht
wenn man auch das könnte aber dafür hat
man die befähigung nicht mehr und jetzt
geht es darum wieder zu befähigen für
die landes- und bündnisverteidigung
aktuell im kern und da will jemand von
herrn von hagens dass er sagt wenn wir
keine auslandseinsätze hätten dann
hätten wir eigentlich das ganze problem
nicht mehr na ja also das ist immer eine
politische frage wo ich welchen
schwerpunkt setze und welche
international verantwortung ich mache
aber fakt ist 1 finanziell prächtig
trotzdem diesen spielraum von 100
milliarden um meine befähigung für die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung wieder
sicherstellen zu können und das wird
einige jahre dauern zum thema wofür klar
persönliche ausstattung der soldatinnen
soldaten weg von der mangel
mangelverwaltung dass wir nicht mehr
funkgeräte schutzwesten 18 geräte
ständig ausbauen müssen 100 kilometer
von a nach b für die übung fahren müssen
zusammen glauben müssen für jetzt kräfte
in litauen dann die dinge die wir seit
langem brauchen selbst von der un immer
wieder angefordert werden hubschrauber
schwere transporthubschrauber die
tornado nachfolge ist seit zehn jahren
ein elementares thema und all das was
wir für die landstreitkräfte brauchen um
wie gesagt unser puzzlestück in nato und
eu einsetzen zu können muss ja immer
wieder sagen das ist international
abgestimmt und da müssen wir jetzt
endlich liefern weil auch alle anderen
ja die situation erkennen und sagen
mensch wie in europa wir müssen jetzt
sehen dass wir unsere architektur wieder
fit bekommen das haben wir 2 prozent
sind eine richtige forderung immer
gewesen wer also mit blick auf unseren
unsere lücken auf jeden fall ich war nie
ein freund von so nation prozentangabe
das war ja immer eher ein politische
zusage mir ging es um die fähigkeiten
aber es war klar wenn man das nach
rechnet kommt man automatisch da hoch
weil so viel abgebaut wurde dass man
jetzt erstmal reinvestieren muss eine
andere chance sehe ich nicht wenn man
den auftrag abgeleitet aus dem
grundgesetz wahrnehmen möchte
hervorragend ich hatte den eindruck sie
wollten wieder sprechen
weil das stimmt ja so nicht herr wissen
wir natürlich sehe ich die lücken und
ich kenne die lücken aber also jetzt zu
sagen da ist alles andere abgebaut
worden was ist denn mit dem
transportflugzeug a400m was ist mit den
korrekten das sind alles dinge die sind
wahnsinnig teuer und die braucht man
nicht nur zum keller auspumpen und ich
auch nicht nur für noch im irak sondern
das sind natürlich auch ganz andere
fähigkeiten die man ausschließlich für
auslandseinsätze braucht und ich finde
um die frage darf man sich jetzt nicht
herumdrücken wenn man sagt wir haben
eine zäsur eine matrix geschichte wenn
wir sagen es gibt jetzt tatsächlich eine
militärische bedrohung durch russland
denn ist das doch genau der moment wo
man nicht sagen muss 100 milliarden über
als früher sondern man sagen muss wir
konzentrieren uns auf landesverteidigung
schluss mit allen auslandseinsätzen das
war im ursprünglichen
grundgesetz auch gar nicht drin und
diese diese geschichte von deutschland
wird am hindukusch verteidigt die hat in
deutschland nie jemand gerollt das war
falsch das wissen wir heute das war aber
auch für jahr 2014 und deswegen finde
ich haben wir jetzt genau die situation
erwarten wir dass sie sagen können okay
a400m compact die korvetten comeback das
kommt ganz vieles anderes wenn sie das
hochrechnen wie viel geld das ist und
davon kriegen sie so viele
nachtsichtgeräte und warme unterwäsche
für die soldatinnen und soldaten ich war
ja bekannt problem aber und her doch
einfach zuhören wie diesen hatten das
ist das ist zu einfach also ein
transportflugzeug braucht man auch um
kräfte an die bündnis grenze zu verlegen
wie jetzt aktuell in richtung litauen
oder vergleichbar das hatten wir auch
schon immer auch für humanitäre un
einsätze hatten wir immer schon mit
blick auf die transall
transportflugzeuge auch schon weit vor
den 90ern stichwort afrika für die
ostsee hatten wir schon immer bestimmte
plattformen und wenn sie mal runter
rechnen woher wir kommen und was wir
heute haben ist das her begrenzt
insbesondere auf die einsatzbereitschaft
aber es geht um befähigungen in gänze
nicht um einzelne waffensysteme dass es
eben zu kurz gedacht mit einem
transportflugzeug stellen sie doch nicht
die luftverteidigung sicher mit jetzt
aktuell sechs eurofightern an der nato
ostgrenze
stellen sie doch nicht die top
luftraumüberwachung sicher mit dem was
wir ihm her gerade hause leisten sie
wissen und sie kennen das operation
läusekamm
1.2.0 versuchen wir gerade die kräfte
zusammen zu stellen die wir zugesagt
haben im bündnis aber eben nicht für die
gesamte bundeswehr und das ist nun mal
die situation also jeder der da
information möchte wie die situation ist
dem kann man das darlegen und froh dass
viele parlamentarier nachfragen und sich
das erklären lassen ich gebe ihnen recht
da ist vieles auch falsch gelaufen den
letzten jahren aber im endeffekt auch
oft politisch motiviert falsch gelaufen
ich dachte sie wollten dann noch gerne
was zu fern wie sie sagen das hatte ich
so verstanden
naja weil er diese das gerade so sagte
das ist die hatte das genannt man muss
das solistisch gesamt sehen und ja also
das einem ausfall des anderen
sondervermögen das sind echt schöne
sozialdemokratische worte er diese mine
gerade geht es ausschließlich um 100
milliarden hat er den letzten vier
wochen irgendwer bundestag über all die
anderen dinge gesprochen gar nicht also
deswegen also das könnte sich für die
galerie auch sparen aber jetzt reden wir
über 100 milliarden über nichts anderes
mehr zu tun das andere kommt irgendwann
später das wissen sie selber das nicht
passiert da kommt keine weiteren 100
milliarden für humanitäre einsätze für
entwicklungshilfe usw auf das 0,7
prozent ziel bei der entwicklungshilfe
warten wir auch schon seit mehreren
jahrzehnten sie auch
sicher können sie sich da sein dass es
das ist ja so diesen gesamten einsatz
gibt und dass es eben dann auch genug
geld eben für all die anderen sachen
gibt ja ich meine das eine oder andere
was wir von van aken gerade an geführt
hat ist sicherlich auch manchmal dem
schwierigen verhältnis der linkspartei
zur bundeswehr generell geschuldet und
zur frage der außen und
sicherheitspolitik wo man nicht mal die
realität sind und nicht ganz angekommen
ist aber noch mal wir haben die klaren
vorgaben dass wir diesen
sicherheitsbegriff ganzheitlich
letztendlich auch betrachten aber noch
mal das eine ist das 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen das andere ist der
bereich wo wir im bereich der
entwicklungshilfe hinschauen müssen aber
genauso gut und das würde ich sagen beim
zivil und katastrophenschutz bei der
frage wie wir demokratie hier bei uns im
land wieder stärken können wir gegen
cyber angriffe vorgehen wie wir auch die
hilfsorganisation das thw stärken können
das sind genauso die fragen die sich
wiederfinden müssen und da werden wir
auch genau hinschauen neben den
aktuellen herausforderungen bei einer
besseren ausrüstung für die bundeswehr
und nur noch mal zur klarstellung diese
100 milliarden inwieweit ist das dann
also die zwei prozent würde es darauf
angerechnet ist dass das geld was man
das dann auch zusätzlich kommen oder wie
muss mir das vorstellen nein die 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen werden
getrennt letztendlich auch betrachtet
die werden wir jetzt auf den weg bringen
die werden wir auch mit gemeinsam in den
ampel koalition aber auch genauso gut
mit cdu/csu war wir brauchen dafür eine
grundgesetzänderung jetzt auf den weg
bringen und das wird glaube ich jetzt
sehr zeitnah oft geschehen auch unter
einbindung natürlich immer des
parlaments war letztendlich ist dass der
haushaltsausschuss der die mittel
freigibt ist da muss ich kurz nachfragen
also habe ich etwas richtig verstanden
herr wiese weil sie als justus
besprochen haben also die 100 milliarden
zusätzlich zu der steigerung auf 2
prozent noch inklusive inklusive eben
anders na ja also einmal klargestellt
frau kommt backe ist ja nicht anders er
also da gibt es die cdu da eigentlich
der bessere partner der gerade darf
er es gibt ja offensichtlich
klärungsbedarf innerhalb der ampel ob
die 100 milliarden auf die zwei prozent
angerechnet werden oder nicht das sind
ja keine details also da bin ich sehr
gespannt auf den gesetzentwurf in den
nächsten tagen aber
es klingt ein bisschen so als würden wir
über ein luxusproblem sprechen wofür
gibt die bundeswehr geld aus der vision
hat eben den breiten bedarf skizziert ja
die truppe ist in einem ganz
offensichtlich beklagenswerten zustand
aber das problem ist ja dass sie nicht
gut in der lage gewesen ist bisher geld
auszugeben stichwort beschaffungswesen
stichwort vergaberecht die vielen
milliarden die es seit 2014 zusätzlich
gegeben hat für die bundeswehr die sind
in weiten teilen nicht in der truppe
angekommen weil sehr viele großvorhaben
sehr viele kleine vorhaben letztlich vor
gericht landen und juristen und anwälte
über die ausrüstung der truppe
entscheiden müssen gerade letzte woche
hat das oberlandesgericht düsseldorf
den prozess zum sturmgewehr 630 eröffnet
also es gibt ja ganz offensichtlich
bürokratische mängel das
verteidigungsministerium die die
bundeswehr daran hindern das geld
tatsächlich auch auszugeben also geld
alleine macht in dem fall die truppe
ganz bestimmt nicht das wäre nämlich
genau die frage eher wissen ist es
wirklich eine frage des geldes oder halt
eben auch der strukturen es gab ja immer
in der diskussion ist das
beschaffungsamt da heißt es dass das das
ja gilt sehr behäbig und ist bekannt für
schwierige entscheidungsprozesse da gibt
es genug kritik daran also was könnte
man auch ändern ohne vielleicht so viel
geld in die mängel sind da die lücken
sind da und wenn man die fühlen möchte
dann kostet das einfach geld jetzt ist
die frage wie mache ich das und da muss
man erklären das beschaffungswesen wurde
ausgerichtet auch verändert im jahr 2010
11 auf abbau und wenn ich eine
organisationsstruktur ihre und von der
kultur her ausrichter auf abbau ist es
schwierig wenn ich eine organisation
dann entsprechend drehen weil ich da man
muss einfach dazu sagen die mitarbeiter
und mitarbeiter dort die leiste nach wie
vor immens viel aber sie arbeiten
natürlich
unter vorgaben und rahmenbedingungen die
politik gesetzt hat also die menschen
dort machen sicher das vergaberecht
nicht selbst oder auch das thema
haushaltsrecht mit blick auf die 25 mio
vorlagen etc das sind abläufe die
politisch gesetzt wurden das würde jetzt
seit jahren bemängelt und jetzt ist die
frage ob es jetzt der
verteidigungsminister gelingt sie hat
das angekündigt sie will das angehen
dieses beschaffungswesen vor dem
hintergrund der rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen zu verändern alle
anderen nationen in europa machen uns
das vor sie haben ja auch europäische
vorgaben und das gilt es jetzt
anzupacken wenn sie wenn ihr das nicht
gelingt wird man die 100 milliarden
nicht in der entsprechenden
geschwindigkeit abfließen lassen können
und wird die bundeswehr in fünf jahren
noch nicht dort haben wo wir sie heute
bräuchten weil ich gerade in welchem
zeitraum denken sie denn jetzt
eigentlich also wann ist die bundeswehr
so weit wie sie sagen ja jetzt sind wir
wirklich jetzt stehen wir wieder gut da
wie ge sein sollten na ja also das ist
wird jetzt eine parlamentarische frage
sein messpunkt zu definieren für den
mittelabfluss und vor allem wofür also
beispielsweise eine komplette division
landstreitkräfte bis ende der
legislaturperiode bin ich gespannt ob
das gelingt mit blick auf das jetzige
beschaffungswesen und vergaberecht
stichwort schwere transporthubschrauber
noch in dieser legislaturperiode dass
das anlaufen dieses projekt tornado
nachfolge wird über mehrere jahre laufen
müssen was den zulauf eines neuen
flugzeuges betrifft da wird man über
mehrere jahre bis 2030 sprechen also zu
glauben wie einige in der koalition
in drei jahren ist das geld aufgebraucht
mitnichten ok herr wiese was heißt das
dann aber dann wenn sie wenn wir jetzt
alle sagen diese ukraine krieg ist eine
zeitenwende wir lernen jetzt dazu wir
müssen auch für solche fälle gerüstet
zahlen was würden sie denn jetzt oder
welchen schluss forderung zehnte dann
daraus was muss dann die bundeswehr
leisten wir haben wir kriegen jetzt viel
applaus voraus der auch von anderen
ländern und ab dem motto die
bundesrepublik es endlich in der
realität angekommen
aber was heißt das denn genau das wird
jetzt in nächster zeit eine
prioritätensetzung geben das was an
ausrüstung letztendlich erforderlich ist
da wird letztendlich vorschläge dann
auch gemacht werden die wir auf den weg
gebracht werden aber ich würde den punkt
noch einmal ansprechen das muss
sicherlich beim beschaffungswesen genau
hingeschaut werden da ist ein
engpass der möglicherweise dazu führt
dass es nicht so schnell geht wenn man
nicht da gewisse strukturelle
verbesserungen nacht da hat die
bundesverteidigungsministerium jetzt
klarere formen angekündigt die müssen
jetzt mit auf den weg gebracht werden
sonst kann das eintreten was herr
wüstener sagt und da muss jetzt
vorgebeugt werden
trotzdem noch mal die frage was heißt
dass grundsätzlich auf eine an sie auch
die frage wenn wir so in diesen ukraine
krieg noch mal mit einbeziehen sie haben
gesagt hat jetzt gar nichts damit zu tun
aber
wenn wir uns vorstellen es gibt wieder
so einen fall also müssen wir uns nicht
darauf schneller dann rüsten und macht
es dann nicht dann doch auch sinn eben
dieses geld so auszugeben
wie dieser prioritätensetzung und ich
glaube das was uns die die die russische
aggression jetzt zeigt ist dass es wird
tatsächlich nicht von freunden umzingelt
sind dass man sich um landes verteidigen
gedanken machen muss und deswegen würde
ich sagen ja prioritätensetzung aber
nicht bei der frage des waffensystems
sondern bei der frage wofür brauchen wir
die bundeswehr wir werden jetzt die
nächsten drei jahren enquete-kommission
untersuchungsausschuss haben im
bundestag um die ganz afghanistan
desaster aufzuarbeiten und ich wünsche
mir dass am ende der priorität rauskommt
wir gehen zurück dahin wo die bundeswehr
kommt auch er wisse es erscheine ich zu
so einem zeitpunkt statt die bundeswehr
eingetreten als sie noch nicht in
auslandseinsätzen war und dann wenn wir
dann diese priorität gesetzt haben dann
ist verteidigung ohne ausland setzte
dann können wir uns genau überlegen
welche waffensysteme brauchen wir dann
tatsächlich gar nicht mehr
wirklich
geld sparen und dann glaube ich dennoch
ist relativ einfach man muss nur die
politische frage zuerst klären und der
die technische welchem system sie von
den linken haben wir die politische
frage so geklärt dass sie gesagt haben
sie wollen die nato gar nicht mehr haben
sehen sie jetzt im moment denn dass die
nato dass es gut ist in der nato zu sein
wenn sogar länder wie finnland neutral
sind gerne mitglied in der nato wären
und die ukraine das auch wäre also wie
beurteilen sie das jetzt angesichts
dieses krieges
also die nato das ist eine relativ
einfache frage die nato krieg des kalten
krieges ist der kalte krieg ist seit 92
verweisen die die nato hat im 21
jahrhundert nichts zu suchen aber
natürlich stellt sich die frage jetzt
noch mal welche arten von
sicherheitsgarantien in europa kann es
geben wenn man sagt keine naht und keine
eu armee und ich finde das ist eine
frage also die diskutieren wir gerade in
der linken und die sollten hier in
deutschland diskutieren aber nato
nato ist teilweise haben sie
angriffskriege geführt es ist wirklich
ein verein der nicht ich sage mal den
deutschen europäischen interessen
nachkommt und deswegen würde ich sagen
nato können wir wirklich sagen sie bloß
werden aber dafür brauchen wir natürlich
was um zum beispiel den baltischen
ländern sicherheitsgarantien geben zu
können da wird sie eben mich auch in den
nächsten jahren von russland überholt
werden das ist völlig klar sowas
brauchen wir aber nochmal dafür nicht
sie sagen wir brauchen die nato nein ich
halte den ansatz für vollkommen falsch
und ich halte ihn auch in der jetzigen
situation für gefährlich ich glaube es
zeigt sich gerade wie wichtig dieses
bündnis letztendlich ist und es ist ja
auch dieses bündnis eine hoffnung vieler
osteuropäischer staaten gerade den
staaten im baltikum letztendlich die auf
dieses bündnis letztendlich auch setzen
wir haben andere länder wo wir
sicherlich vor einem monat noch gedacht
hätten dass sie sehr zurückhaltend
gegenüber der nato sind finnland ist
angesprochen und diese position von
herrn van aken und in der linkspartei
die halte ich wirklich in der jetzigen
diskussion für sehr gefährlich auch wenn
ich äußerungen von frau wagenknecht
gegenüber russland auch noch mal in
letzter zeit gehört habe also von daher
ich kann davor letztendlich nur wann ich
glaube viele bürgerinnen bürger sind
froh dass wir in diese strukturen
eingebunden sind dass wir diesen
rückhalt innerhalb der bestehende nato
strukturen auch haben und das jetzt
sozusagen aufs spiel zu setzen und das
auch so ein bisschen lächerlich als
verein darzustellen das halte ich für
höchst gefährlich in der aktuellen
situation wenn die nato so wichtig ist
dann hätte man doch schon viel früher
auch den sie mit zwei prozent ziel
eigentlich zustimmen müssen
rückblickend ist das sicherlich etwas
wenn wir vor drei vier jahren das in
dieser konsequenz gehabt hätten was wir
heute jetzt erlebt haben dann hätte man
sich ja vielleicht einige diskussionen
auch anders geführt ich glaube aber dass
olaf scholz deutlich gemacht hat dass
dieses ausmaß des russischen
angriffskrieges auch für viele so nicht
erwartbar gewesen ist wie es dann
gekommen ist und darum ist es ja auch
wichtig diesen begriff der zeitenwende
hier verwendet zu haben und jetzt
sicherlich diskussionen auch anders zu
führen weil es hier einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
gegeben und die sache ist noch mal der
für viele ein paar tage vorher in dieser
dimension nicht vorstellbar gewesen ist
die cdu-frau kompakte sieht es auch als
anlass diese zeiten wenn er zum beispiel
auch wieder über eine wehrpflicht oder
eine dienstpflicht zu sprechen was
erwarten sie da noch erwarten sie da
noch weitere diskussionen die jetzt
durch diesen krieg ausgelöst werden
also das waren ja einzelne stimmen
einzelne debattenbeiträge innerhalb der
union die jetzt auch nicht
aus der ersten reihe haben möchte ich
mal sagen die debatte ist relativ beide
verstummt und ich glaube auch aus
einigen guten recht ehrlich gesagt also
die wehrpflicht ist abgeschafft es gab
gute gründe dafür und ich glaube das
haben eine wiedereinführung der
gegenwärtigen bedrohungslage auch nicht
gerecht würde was die bundeswehr braucht
sind
professionelle kräfte und nicht wie
rekruten die haben kurz durchgeschleust
werden und
deswegen hat die militärs ähnlich
generalinspekteur zurück jordan hat sich
da sehr klar positioniert also ich
glaube diese debatte diese debatten
dient vielleicht eher dazu
uns uns abzulenken von den
gräueltaten von dem verbrechen was sich
da gerade auf ukrainischem boden und
ukrainischer luft ereignet da ist es
mitunter leichter sich mit eigenen
befindlichkeiten mit
selbstreferentiellen debatten wie einer
wiedereinführung der wehrpflicht zu
beschäftigen als mit der frage wie wir
mit diesen moralischen dilemma dass
jeder tag dieses krieges eben auch für
uns bedeutet umgehen da vista wie ist da
also zum ein baby stark wie beurteilen
sie die gefahr die auch für uns besteht
in diesem krieg und wie denkt man in der
truppe darüber also was du warst wie ist
die idee die stimmung angesichts dieses
krieges in der truppe ist es eher so
dass man bezogen auf das was jetzt
passiert die rede von kanzler scholz das
auch erst mal als art befreiungsschlag
empfindet weil zumindest wir ja
innerhalb der bundeswehr der
sicherheitspolitischen community über
die jahre hinweg gewarnt haben und das
interessante ist vieles im
strategiepapieren auch politisch
weißbuch konzeption der bundeswehr
fähigkeitsprofil auch immer politisch
gehackt wurden aber es wurde nie
unterfüttert und weil wir uns hier alle
der soldatenberuf ist ein extrem
politiker berufen beschäftigt haben wie
sich die welt verändert dann ist das
jetzt erst mal nur sehr positiv dass es
dass sich endlich politik auf macht und
sagt wir müssen wieder in die wehr
fähigkeit
investieren und was die ukraine
anbelangt das sind alle natürlich tief
betroffen sie fühlen mit was da jetzt
passiert sie wissen auch warum man jetzt
eine eine bündnisverpflichtungen
natürlich auch wahr machen muss an der
ostgrenze und dieses dienen wo für eine
kernfrage der inneren führung unserer
führungsphilosophie wurde dahingehend
noch nie so klar beantwortet wie aktuell
vor dem hintergrund des jetzigen
konflikt dass deswegen will ich sagen
ist die stimmung bezogen auf den
konflikt auf der einen seite entsetzen
auf der anderen seite professionell in
den auftrag gehen in litauen in rumänien
wo auch immer und dennoch auch ein
positives gefühl weil politik endlich
eine realität anerkennt oder das
unterfüttert was 2016 mit weiss' buch
geschrieben ist und wer hat denn die
realität so lange nicht anerkannt
geräten gibt deswegen machen sie dafür
verantwortlich da geht es ja um die
frage von mehrheiten und der wahrnehmung
es waren ja sehr viele in den fraktionen
die geworben haben gesagt wir müssen uns
wieder auf landes- und
bündnisverteidigung konzentrieren wir
brauchen strukturelle veränderung wir
brauchen das auffüllen der lücken wir
müssen anders in eu nato agieren aber es
gab eben keine mehrheiten und manche
wahrheiten brauchen ihre zeit und
manchmal erst zu tragisch es klingt so
ein furchtbaren krieg wird er wiese wo
sehen sie eine möglichkeit auch für die
bundeswehr jetzt auch in diesem krieg
noch etwas zu leisten etwas gutes zu tun
gegen diesen krieg
ich glaube dass die bundeswehr sehr viel
tut letztendlich die bundeswehr ist an
der nato ostflanke letztendlich die
bundeswehr leistet
unterstützungsleistungen und von daher
kann man den soldatinnen und soldaten
die da im einsatz sind die mit anpacken
auch nur den dank aussprechen in dieser
situation wir alle hoffen natürlich dass
diese kriegerische auseinandersetzung
zeitnah möglicherweise ein ende findet
aber die dramatischen bilder die wir
momentan sehen dass weitere vorrücken
der russischen truppenteile trotz eines
beachten widerstandes den die ukraine
okarina leisten die wird es zeigt mir
eigentlich dass wir uns noch auf
dramatische tage und wochen einstellen
müssen herr van aken jetzt gibt es
morgen ein gespräch zwischen den beiden
außenministern russland und ukraine es
in der türkei wie viel hoffnung haben
sie dass diplomatie doch noch irgendwie
ja etwas lösen kann und nicht nur das
militär
am ende wird das lösen ich glaube aber
nicht morgen ich glaube das dauert noch
die erfahrung aus anderen kriegen zeigt
ja dass kriege dank zu ende gehen wenn
beide seiten gleichermaßen bereit sind
cremes verhandlungen zu führen das sehe
ich im moment nicht weil die kriegsziele
russland sind andere deswegen glaube ich
morgen sie war noch nicht viel aber
natürlich müssen wir auch die diplomatie
setzen und das eine das was mich auch
die ganzen tage jetzt umtreibt ist das
eine ist der was aktuell passiert was
wir aktuell richtig machen müssen aber
wir müssen ja auch die zukunft denken
was kommt denn danach was kommt auch in
der nacht putin zeit und da machen wir
dann machen wir dann schon auch dinge
sorgen wie in finnland jetzt in dem
motto ein trip das finde ich total
verständig das finde ich ja nicht heute
aber wie wollen wir dann eine
friedensordnung in 10 oder 15 jahren
hinbekommen wie wollen wir dann jemals
wieder eine kooperative sicherheit
bündnis hier auf diesem kontinent mit
russland kennen bekommen in einer nacht
putin zeit das gleiche mit dem mit dem
aufrüsten diese 100 milliarden wenn ja
auch ein startschuss zum wettrüsten sein
dann sind wir wieder da wo wir in den
60er 70er und 80er jahren waren mit all
den negativen konsequenzen
das sind alles dinge die mir im moment
zu wenig bedacht werden ich glaube es um
langfristig denken und und im korb immer
im kopf haben es kommt eine zeit nach
putin macht dieser russischen das heißt
dass heinzl gebirgen auf dauer
das heißt sie würden sehr dafür
plädieren dass die ukraine ja neutral
bleibt und eben nicht mitglied der nato
wird was ja jetzt auch schon
angedeutet hat dass das eine möglichkeit
wäre
das kann ganz allein die ukraine
entscheiden ich finde das anmaßend wenn
wir hier in deutschland sagen die kleine
soll neutral bleiben das ist liegt nicht
an uns dass müssen die entscheiden
natürlich wäre es perspektivisch eine
gute lösung
und wahrscheinlich müsste der westen die
eu deutschland der ukraine entsprechende
angebote machen wenn es dann in die
richtung geht das für die ukraine etwas
sinnvolles ist aber ich werde jetzt
nicht hingehen und sagen hier ukraine
müssen frei sein das ist eine souveräne
entscheidung der drei noch nicht muss
frau kompakt was erwarten sie wenn
dieser krieg noch länger noch länger
dauert wie viel was was was wird das
noch verändern und welche neuen
diskussionen wird wird es da vielleicht
noch geben auch in bezug auf
sicherheitspolitik und deutschlands
rolle in der welt
ja ich fürchte tatsächlich dass dieser
krieg ein langwieriger werden wird der
nato generalsekretärs deutenberg hat vor
einigen tagen gesagt das sei jetzt das
neue normal das ist ein satz der bei mir
muss ich sagen doch noch nachhallt und
ich fürchte dass er damit beschrieben
hat dass wir in einer zeit fortwährender
spannung leben werden der westen europa
auf der einen seite russland auf der
anderen seite diese spannung entlädt
sich gerade heiß und blutig und
kriegerisch in der ukraine der passieren
dinge die viele nicht allzu schnell
vergessen werden die ukraine am
allerwenigsten
ja die ersten sprechen von einem kalten
krieg 2.0 okay vielleicht ist es genau
das worauf es hinausläuft er wissen
haben sie noch hoffnung dass das nicht
so lange dauert nein das ist doch das
wird noch länger dauern leider gottes
und die große herausforderung ist nicht
nur das was wir heute diskutiert haben
die stärkung der sicherheitsarchitektur
in europa die große herausforderung ist
wie wir langfristig diplomatisch wieder
dinge lösen können und natürlich
national wie wir mit dem thema
flüchtlinge und energiepreise in den
nächsten monaten aber auch jan umgehen
vielen dank herr wie es nachher wiese
herr van aken und frau kompakte vielen
dank irgendwas zu schauen genau über die
frage ob diese oder diplomatie noch eine
lösung sein kann darüber diskutieren wir
dann morgen anlässlich des gespräches
der beiden außenminister machen sie es
gut hier geht's weiter mit phoenix der
tag mit thomas bade bis dahin tschüss
[Musik]